- [Narrator] This is what it sounds like
when 3,500 people are eating together.
And another 3,500.
And another.
In total, today, the
Shirdi Sai Baba Temple
in Maharashtra, India
will serve lunch to at least
40,000 people for free.
And this happens every
day, 365 days a year.
The temple was built in 2008,
around a specific philosophy
by spiritual leader Sai Baba.
This is the man in charge.
He supervises the kitchen, or mega kitchen
as this is one of the largest in Asia.
The day, it starts at 6:30 in the morning.
Some people are cooking vegetables.
Some clean utensils.
Some are responsible for the bread.
You get it.
Every day, the meal is different.
But the ratio is always the same.
To make these plates
for 40,000 people a day,
it takes a lot of food.
Here are the numbers.
3.3 tons of bread.
Two tons of vegetables.
Nearly one ton of lentils.
And half a ton of dessert.
Now, to make all this food,
the kitchen requires a lot of power.
The roof is covered in solar panels.
So, it's clear this temple's initiatives
are something to be proud of.